what's up fool what's a full podcast
with Felipe Esparza I was rivet aureus
Lisa Esparza the Wheels of Steel over
there texting during a social media
because my advice to anybody out there
always ask me man Felipe I'm going on my
own podcast and I want you to be a guest
no I'm not gonna be a guest happy on the
gas on a pod camera four episodes first
of all it's not even established yet I
don't know what the hell you're doing
I don't wanna get to your place and you
have no studio the place more like socks
once I smell socks I'm like a shark time
bro I'm out cuz if I could smell socks
that mean the ass is dirty what's
everything
elves its dirty bro once I smell sucks
I'm out like the dirty sock smell they
smell like old bread yeah so I want my
advice
and I'd like to Rodrigo when he did his
podcast and I told George Martine when
they did the podcast have budget part
can record it before you release some at
least ten we can't do ten seven ten man
and every week release one and then you
have 10 weeks brain to do another show
like me though it's hard man to start
out with just one yeah man it is hard
you totally with one I put on five five
rubber the foot one was tough huh who
we're doing Oh jam I need a producer
yeah did you start out knowing what
you're gonna say [ __ ] no you announced
it
can we have 30 episodes 38 yo yo yo yo
yo yo yo keeps going really Barcelona
show bro ah Big Dawg thoughtful talk
like Kenya Westbrook a hangout bro
like in every every word had to be
prolific hey bro I'm just here to spread
now
better get that fool here but I wanna
doing a live show bro there could be a
lot witnessing yeah we exploding bro
we're gonna get you the hard question
right now bro he just like that what a
politician I'll go to Fox News Service
cheering them on people nobody wants to
explode over 100 then we don't want to
go with one somebody to just walk out of
an interview when they get uncomfortable
like it you can't walk on her interview
on live audience row you gotta sit there
and take it
[ __ ] yeah maintain your composure but
I've been listen to it man but I've
heard some of it about the Laugh Factory
and stuff like that mm-hmm but even know
when the laugh at you here the first
time I heard of Latino night anywhere
first time the Laugh Factory I'm gonna
say the Latino Laugh Factory the Latino
night at that effect Monday's didn't
actually get started with boomer and
Palmers word on the street you guys had
lines around Laurel Canyon
well that food was dressing bro like I
don't know what happened with to Patong
people like in the 90s like Danny was
trying to come back oh yeah people were
trying to push it but nobody really went
for it still watched you work t-shirts
with with I'm like those loose I don't
know what they're straps on a bag of the
gene and then the front part of me
leather and they were a leather hat and
I was a before ed hardy huh yeah though
the beginning of douchey don't let the
beginning bro baby dude but right after
that studs you know those thugs came
back ranch don't join me dude I'm going
strong bro with deep pockets true legend
bro Jonas or Jerry - Josh - Josh Nasar
Josh masters is a reformed and admitted
reformed
douche bag dresser I was John Massey
came in the photo to laugh at you bro
forget we talked about in a podcast I
never seen a guy walking was another
woman and she had a chain wallet too
gangsta like a chain walk this was a
part of a ninja force crew in West
Hollywood
hardcore Hollywood outfit we lost
another comedian bro like three of them
right no the other one with already
passed away okay the one in there but
just bowed out all right now yes the
dickey-fuller yeah man yeah man that guy
used to be of the Golden State Warriors
warrior mascot mascot if you guys go
back to the Michael Jordan days he used
to be the mascot he's to jump on a
trampoline and do a backflip and then
slam dunking the ball slam dunk on a
basket in point of Jordan that's how we
do it yeah I remember he told that story
smoked with Latrice burro the treats
freewill spree was I wouldn't come over
those three well rims right in that was
a little bit right before when he choked
the coach
that fool said Mario Cruz is under for
Georgia's one so fool welcome everybody
who's watching us right now live on
YouTube and man that's a good joke you
just said over there I never thought
about it but that's hilarious I might go
home and take my t-shirt off and change
it but now it's too late that for sale
would you get a job at Trader Joe's room
[Laughter]
yeah bro look at Twitter Jones brought
our parking enforcer bro do you need
bags you know what Lassa where's the
baby I love last hour one more baby
Pleasant Hill California hello Pleasant
here where's Pleasant Hill up there next
to Pleasanton yeah
next to Roseville Roseville all that
[ __ ]
I'm coming so ladies and gentlemen drama
start all over
upcoming shows Ignacio Colorado ask iu
Catina casino that's tomorrow Saturday
May 19
Larry bubbles Braun the Regal Taurus
Charlie Rogan the man the main
the man was shoulder shoulder blades
Irvine improv California May 24 through
27 oh [ __ ]
we have a good show this week well goody
who's gonna show up on Thursday then
disappear and go to Mexico and bring
back my toe jam and go to Mexico for a
wedding never seen one and then he's
trying to go - no you're not gonna go
anywhere you're gonna stay with us also
Miami may 31st about the Magic City
casino I'm headlining the ultimate Miami
comedian competition and closing it out
with an hour-long set to be badass we
called a quick our Loretto coffee also
El Paso San Antonio and Orlando coming
up in June
check out Felipe worldcom slash tour
because I'm adding new dates all the
time and we're gonna be June 10th we're
in the Long Beach Laugh Factory his
latino night so check that out and also
June 11 June 12th is gonna be Riverside
box theater but birthdays June 10 crash
at Long Beach is Sunday the day before
your birthday and the Riverside show I
saw Benny man on a flyer for a comedy
show and I was shocked
was that with in wonder white I was
shocked well it was clean comedy yeah
yeah and wanted comedy funny comedy
expose how did clean how did he clear
that joke yum yum yum yum yum yum
okay I went to nanny I was upon man like
um I remember just older comics or yeah
I think people were just when it went to
college I guess they weren't a college
first in this idea you know what I have
a better dream of being a stand-up
comedian I didn't go to Carly I do want
to be a comedian my whole life so I went
to I went to four years of drug
addiction first instead of college I
cleaned up I realized I wanna be a
comedian
well yeah backpacking in Echo Park
backpacking at the Holly River I was
River dancing
that's a good one let me use that later
so we got my point well the food come on
yeah so every every time I see a
documentary about comedians and I'm
gonna saying I'm just go out and just
stare bro white comedians right they
always have a set list for every [ __ ]
show they're gonna do like oh this is my
my this is my joke when I do a clean
show look at my jokes when I do a set
that's more more blue these are my 30
minutes sadly when I gotta do a Latino
room is it my 20 minute set of things
not to do in a black show you know it
like they have to have a list of jobs
they're gonna do in a certain place
whatever happened to just write jokes
that are funny that everybody had a
laugh at kind of categorize and I think
they gotta be like oh yeah like every
every documentary about comedy comedians
in this show the white comedians like
even Ori
orny Adams corny orny Adams already had
on that Seinfeld show he had a box of
scripts that he read it he had a set
list you see it's a joke yes I got my
pizza I got my I got I got I got tongue
I'm Jewish I got tons of material for
doing engineer jokes I got tons of stuff
on East India and I got tons of this
stuff and I got tons of that hey I'm
getting ready for somebody to book me
well then you see do you see these guys
do a show before you it is a staying
[ __ ] jokes like nothing new bro like
if you can't write a joke that's gonna
work everywhere drop it I thought I
might buy for any comedian out there man
or don't take the gig like I never I
never have to change my job to perform
anywhere except I might take the word
[ __ ] out [ __ ] [ __ ] mister [ __ ] you
[ __ ] ass you know I take those words
out and I did a short one where I
couldn't stay abreast or bosom bro I
couldn't even mention any anatomy of the
woman's body so so now I offend
everybody I am a changed I turn it
around and I stand out yeah one instead
instead of saying that I was a woman she
took her clothes off and her clothes and
her body opened up like a life raft but
I couldn't stay there's a lot of ladies
there I just changed there you know when
I get home I think my open up my path
I opened a life raft and my arms other
other other oars but didn't I didn't
have to go there right 35 minutes of
hacky walmart Joe's bro it was a game
program here man I'm gonna say that I'm
the best but I don't you don't do it
like yeah I don't do it that way man I
don't do that what do you think look at
it I think a lot of comedians now man
they pick comedy shows like like boxers
pick fights like they feel like he's an
animal
yeah he's an animal at the hobby store
only only other times he's doing editing
he's doing videos most of the time but
for reals like all this guy because this
guy he's an animal bro he's ferocious
yeah he's ferocious in that room full of
white people where everybody knows him
from a popular podcast everybody's there
to cheer him on but bro where's the UH
where's a true grinning wheres you can
you pop in on a black chocolate sundae
and after a 5-minute set can you bunk
and you walk into my Amy Schumer in
between the black audience hey uh excuse
me um can I go out right now Tony Rock
nah man nah I'm doubting man I've had
I've had black comedians tell me a
couple tell me that they don't feel
comfortable doing chocolate sundae
because they are more reserved type
comics they're not like what they called
themselves they're not Def Jam style
comics they don't come out there with
like the self hype and all that stuff
but it doesn't matter who you are I've
worked chocolate sundaes for years it
was one of the best nights to work but
it didn't matter who you were as a comic
if you were funny they didn't care or
whatever like bombing hurts yeah all
mean hurts getting up there and getting
no laughs for ten minutes it's a long
time man they could feel at 45 I went
through 12 hours 20 minutes of material
one time
you can happen man I think they just
don't want to bomb they're afraid
they're so so scared you know what they
like to be the big fish in a little pool
well also like chocolate sundaes can
feel like Apollo like Showtime at the
Apollo where it's they're ruthless when
they when they're ruthless but if you're
funny it's a real test of whether you're
funny or not but I see people there's
also people that only kill chocolate
sundae but you put up somewhere people
are quiet and then he can't really talk
to the audience bro cause he's used to
go back were you from your maybe shut up
you know but he looks odd it was really
quiet they get really nervous
oh man I need somebody co-op there was
energy before me my hype man for real
man other other other people who are
geniuses are comedy only performing one
club the atom was bro it's true though
or a count or like this guy has this
killer bit I can't really try it I can't
wait to him to do it but while you're
excited about his joke write your own
[ __ ] jokes
I hate comedians man you know you know
they they put on a piece of paper they
put down their phone and there's a
picture of their glasses and then
there's a notebook pencil maybe a cup of
coffee and they grind like everybody
lied to us now social media first time
you can let people cannot talk without
just being free they got a construct a
big sentence and leave a message out
there or or like when every time I go
read for a project and it's written by
Latino there's always a [ __ ] message
bro why don't that be a [ __ ] message
can we just forget have a [ __ ] show
where people die and there's no like
nobody feeling sorry for each other
nobody nobody said oh man that that's a
lung that's the wrong attitude represent
us
there's a proud of our Latino community
bro like the wrong Latino represent a
sort of apology the numbers that mean
George Lopez doesn't represent me the
representative of people totally like I
don't represent a lot of people I
represent the ghetto a [ __ ]
I represent the people man who called
him sick to work from the car in the
parking lot yeah but I wonder when I saw
Joel of apology the first I thought yeah
these people wrapping me that's the way
I feel it the way I talk but I never
felt like to say like if they were like
they represent me good now pick
knowledge states of the politico and
their people say [ __ ] they're you know
crazy oh you don't like him no homie
what have you done Oh or maybe even an
african-american can I make a million
dollar before somebody took it I took it
I have coin you don't man we need money
for this now
Pico Union gym we're routing funds in
like white convenience could just be
comedian nobody goes on a jurist I mean
you know representing Israel man you see
all that bombing that's going on and
guys that don't you care [ __ ] start
out to deal with Gaza what we should do
is just bare rocks what's up fool show
coming up yeah dude little fool that
meet you you wanna slap your back what's
up fool man what's up is that you dudes
I guess but we just invite him to our
show Yemen
what's our full drama club podcast
Steph and Max my glasses gonna put a bun
drama club with death and me and I said
max because I start from the corner of
my peripheral you know why follow me
glasses
well there's 65 old lady lo mirrors oh
no no she they loaded to me I was doing
a show in DC you know check she gave me
something to read and I'm gonna read it
what are you literate - oh my god
literally - what else that like would
you think about first
so what fool the fool the one that seems
over there hot and I'm Vega the color in
a spacesuit the weight Newton others
they share it has those 65 year old lady
than up there the way nuts oh wait yeah
[Music]
good idea
Oh a woman shouting she's looking down
her blouse tipping right yeah how about
every airport do it yeah I don't know
but I couldn't do any time personally I
know this guy's boner is like a few feet
from my face men do shoeshine and and
when I speak to them they always gotta
put an act
you just carry you can be a shy man with
good teeth
he can't be you gotta have a little axe
or when I talk to a shoeshine guy who
sings together Oh act like he takes his
teeth out and his shoeshine with no
teeth nice he has dirty shoes and he
dresses up you know like he's in a
musical Newsies
and he when he's shining them real fast
he makes a little noise so it looks like
going faster it'll pop you go then they
tip me extra but I what he really told
me what I really do is I run like two
after our clubs for two in the morning
they run to 11 in the morning then he
showed me a photo of him at the clubs
for he just gave him Mike Epps concert
yes
and you had a nice hat it was pretty wet
man and everybody were looking night but
when he goes to work in the morning back
to my shoes off looking like Geppetto
for Pinocchio so when so fool we have
our staff and me here man would you get
from I'll just tell your podcast for
12-ton of the budget podcast we want to
know we have fools here excited isn't it
don't even care you know I can't wait
but there are into our social media and
our celebrities and draw my teams the
everything man I know a lot of [ __ ] that
went down when I'm with Mike Epps it
went by Roy went crazy
people were talking about it when he
brought a kangaroo on stage Roy he
brought him on stage and then the
kangaroo was doing Westside he was he
almost let Mike Epps and in the morning
but I have posted a video before my abs
when I was dazed with a kangaroo and I
but I went home to my hotel room with
him we were very very tired
we probably fell asleep around 1:00 in
the morning and we just motor fall
asleep in the morning though I was a
hater
I was against animals you cut yourself
even you fat piece of [ __ ]
would you care about animals did you
know a positive Boulder
but I've eaten kangaroo before in this
delicious nice but I was an animal hater
and I don't know why you know then I
went to Mike Epps page and PETA when it
was on here man he had to pay money for
animal shelters everything he gave me a
text or do we r just friends and we like
to talk [ __ ] so we just started
podcasting together yeah so that I like
to say that we also try to think of
something that we could do together that
did not require talent no offense with
your jingle there here man what a person
made us great impersonations cardi B I
should I should add that to my from
Barbie but we were fans of Rodrigo
because we kidding me we went to UC
Riverside that's where we became yeah so
shout out to Riverside oh yeah man I'm
from Fontana though Vaughn tuck it in
the house Fontana I'm from what the
malla originally was it expensive it was
expensive yeah and it took for [ __ ]
ever but you know I did it I'm gonna
vote this year which I'm real excited
yeah have you been a permanent residence
since I was a senior in high school so
it was easy for her
no tough for me
studying sure in Canada I come back with
no money because I'm I I really have to
pay for it cause the trip becomes this
grad to get into care last time and when
I came back home penniless there should
be a plaque of you right there in Canada
multi horse come out one guy from Canada
Tony and Holly you know he had an old
thing in his past from when he was 18 or
19 and he's like 50 something now and he
still has trouble crossing a letter you
have to get a letter to come back and
forth when you go to Canada even if you
have a clean record they'll find
something if you got arrested when you
were ten for marijuana do you eyes
possession yeah even no matter how old
you were so yeah speaking of that Chris
Brown couldn't get any remember Chris
another yeah a few years ago he had
because of his criminal right yeah he
had shown up to the border he did some
shows in New York and then he had four
sold-out shows through Live Nation up in
Canada and he couldn't cross then they
showed up with
they had semis there was lighting gear
and every because because they didn't
let him in he hadn't been cleared wow I
bet you he cried at the border because I
see man I've seen people get turned down
and they have to go back to Indonesia
and man they're crying but the people
never other paperwork together though
that's true too he had anything he
hadn't he just thought he could cross
and they said no no you got this thing
in your background they're like wait we
have four sold-out
[Laughter]
when I went to when I went to Mexico
over to a place called Rocky Point were
to Penasco and Sonora will cry see now
to our Phoenix Tucson I mean whatever I
resorted to go to Mexico
members of scariest [ __ ] every man they
pulled over all of us yeah and all these
soldier were young do like trigger-happy
product yet those bro like young bro
they were young dude another man would
kill us all right here yeah there was
one through everything really opened up
every box and nothing even our wallets
everything then he finally did it
through but they had to pay them to
bring all the equipment here they were
shopping they could they be intimidating
right Mexico our soldiers are
intimidating they'll do anything
applejack Ali wants to know if anybody
moved to Canada after Trump elected yeah
bro your mom moved out nobody commander
yes in command and commander he goes up
a stage with a bazooka yeah I was just
saying like they're their army has like
messed up guns by El commander video
this guy come up with bazookas abolish
they're shooting our shirts I see the
phone tells me you these are core
bodyguards
oh right and his bulletproof vest is
like Gucci so I respect it oh nice it's
all I [ __ ] g-unit type [ __ ] basically
just the hardcore version of they
started that [ __ ] 40 years ago but they
more like other fans young or the old
old people young fools like young lady
product oldest fans are in their 30s
cool we're doing that show band feud
with other bands and like cartels do oh
yeah they talk little [ __ ] wars on
social media and [ __ ] but the thing with
like if you guys remember like 10 years
ago that dude by the teen le sorry he
was taught they told him how to sing the
song in Sonora and they blasted that for
after he's the last major four to get
killed on stage yeah actually got killed
for some [ __ ] like that yeah
but supposedly he was into other [ __ ]
but all those who the [ __ ] with those
[ __ ] cry babies right like to talk
[ __ ] but when it's hard to get all sad
now another way he went Hollywood no bro
you were having [ __ ] cry-baby
we were burbank no man america say that
I work at Trader Joe's the night a
little sabi cashews that man yeah
traitor peppers bro so how long I've
been doing a podcast and working people
listen to it we've been doing our
podcast for going on two months yeah I
think we're brand brand new oh yeah yeah
you can find us on iTunes stitcher
SoundCloud anywhere you listen to
podcast and we're just the drama club
every Thursday yeah
we're like 12 deep yeah we just had our
tenth anniversary I had to take me out
on a date I think if you want to start
with one I would start with our either
you like our monica lewinsky yeah that
episodes hilarious what happened you had
the drift here no but I found out that
Monica Lewinsky Salvadorian and I lost
my [ __ ] oh wow she was her dad her dad
was born there and he moved here when he
was like 14
so shout out to her dad was Jewish
yeah they're their grandparents or
something fled Europe so his parents
moved to Assad and then he was born
there
that's true I'm trying to find out why
so many German influences in Mexico and
I looked it up me max Emilio bro in
French that's crazy huh all [ __ ]
South America had a German colony bro no
all Amana we have so many accordion
players
[Laughter]
Oh watching this the stand-up comedian
in Mexico and and like man I was
thinking back to Josie Spanish I think
gonna say you have to dress like a clown
because for some reason everyone over
there yeah a character like a Miss yeah
are you the bumblebee in the Simpsons or
he need a little person that was a real
dude though now 22 to sell insurance on
channel 22 dressing a bumble bee suit I
want to do I have okay did I make this
up or does Dom Francisco have a sex
scandal no you wrote that in our list of
scandals I know he's German German
German I think he did I think he did
laureate that he had the trafficking
scandal they had a Netflix movie about
her and they kind of glossed over that
[ __ ] hmm I was disappointed
francisco there so what do you go back
to work already
alright guys I'm out Ari listen later
how about you now just listen to it
later who's gonna be our our Mexican
bass have German instrumental hello
German brought the beer and some of the
oldest Mexicans we were started by the
German that's true and she's cheese
cheese to factory you sit down there yes
Cheesecake Factory cheese makers and
beer makers cut northern Mexico mmm Oh
we're trying to colonize got kicked out
what's up fool mad German Jew what are
the what's the latest scandal right I do
you have talking about bringing it up
right here you're into crack telling me
earlier which one Francis Cobain oh yeah
yeah it's been cocaine yeah I mean
Cobain is getting divorced right I know
she like 12
yeah she's getting divorced and the
judge said that her now ex-husband can
have Kurt Cobain's guitar from the
unplugged episode episode and it's
allegedly worth millions so that's some
[ __ ] that's his that's his
settlement like yeah yeah because she's
worth four hundred five saying I'll take
that I think she gets a lot more of it
Courtney does have say I think over this
table some sort of control like voting
rights and all that stuff I comes to
Nirvana stuff and I don't know I think
the Kurtz Duffy I feel like most of it
goes to Francis yeah she used to fight
with Dave Grohl all the time yeah yeah
how would the daughter know she's gotta
be close to thirty yeah he died she's
like our 93 or something right
didn't even know breaking news Kurt
Cobain is dead I heard it first from the
drama club the guy for the mentors he
said that I could L do yeah I'll further
mom of money to kill him oh that was
[ __ ] it was him and another floor
and another band today he drove him up
to Seattle he shot him in the face it
was all this dude named Allen wrench for
a mother's band called Allen wrench and
uh they used to open for the mentors and
supposedly they went over there but it
was all [ __ ] stories they're just
trying to get publicity yeah and it
worked to be on a documentary oh we
brought you vegan cupcakes because we
know you're vegan thank you you're
welcome and we don't like to show up
empty-handed because our moms taught us
right any other little stories oh one of
my favorite episodes it's all about
Natalie Wood yeah her life and
mysterious death because they reopened
the case right right they did very
recently and he's a person of interest
right Robert Wagner is yeah yes Armando
Armando's brother-in-law cuz we're gonna
investigate that right yeah Gloria is
his brother years ago we were we're
eating and that guy mentioned it what's
it uh wasn't Christopher Walken on that
book well yeah yeah it sounds like the
worst yeah the whole trip sounds
horrible they're wasted and fighting the
whole time all together yeah everybody
everybody and then she died at the end
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
the right base has done computer just
furiously typing comments on this he's
passed on his cat so my favorite story
about Natalie Wood is that everybody was
having sex with everyone on the set so
everybody was having sex with each other
on the set of rebel without a cause
right so they decided to have an orgy
and they have this origin is this they
decided to get it started like in this
bathtub so they fill the bathroom actors
that's the method that's an actor studio
[ __ ] so they filled up this bathtub with
hot water and Natalie gets in first but
she burns her lady partly apart for toes
how did she enter the water where that's
the first thing and that's why that
episode is called [ __ ] first because
that's how she wanted the bathtub first
but she so so she burns her lady parts
and they have to call off the orgy and
then from then on whenever they went to
have parties they would always bring
that [ __ ] up and cloud on her like
remember that time Nathalie [ __ ] up
the origin got beat up she's got
beautiful stories she said that's what
I'm saying but already Bernie before she
got their excuse to get out yeah the
orgy with James Dean carnal were these
dudes Oh giant number two I also like
the two Park episode because we talked
about the recent investigation that they
did in two puff daddy's so-called
involvement and what's been going down
with that well they're saying that Puff
Daddy allegedly paid someone to kill
Tupac while at Greenblatt's diner yeah
next to yeah and I was telling me that's
not an appropriate restaurant to talk
about paid murder but I think it's
perfect I think like where else are you
gonna talk about a hit on somebody it
has to be I Greenblatt's yeah yeah right
next to right after you order the
Southern Fried Chicken the best Oh son
Paul Rodriguez called readjusted his
contract with poor local and we were
eating that that restaurant and a
chicken fried chicken with a market
pesto sauce and he looked he reached
over me was
[Laughter]
but the waiters though I can't imagine
you're talking about murder there
because the waiters there are always
back at your table they're very
attentive their nose very nosy yeah very
in your they're just good they're all
very good and they stay there a long
time all those waiters I imagined it
like at the they have mad lavish parties
but now I'm gonna go play no murder man
cuz I read I saw Jamie Foxx in the
article on our interview and they were
talking about throwing a party and I'm
he I'm Jamie Foxx went to go throw a
party went to P Diddy party he was a man
he said a million dollar and his party
what I mean Jamie [ __ ] goes bro you give
me $400 but throw a mean party in
Hollywood so and he did and then I cuz
I'm but what I'm thinking that if I
don't think P Diddy step again I could
plan a murder if he came to plan another
party yeah thanks good kill somebody get
away with it have a little-person meet
you or the guy you wanna kiss pick up a
little person by the ankle and swing
with the other guy and it look like
somebody threw a little person out of a
roof killed them no witnesses somebody
get me Brett Williams like George
Wallace in the perfect murder you pick
somebody up and you hit the other guy
with them and what's up with what other
stories anything like [ __ ] that we
don't nobody knows about that you guys
know about mmm we were talking a little
bit damages about the time that Eddie
Murphy got pulled over for solicitation
everybody
they know what they know tell the sex
worker Salim are she ended up dying a
year later under mysterious
circumstances and Eddie Murphy paid for
some private investigation right yeah
because she they found her dead on the
lawn in front of her apartment building
in just her lingerie and allegedly she
got locked out of her apartment and she
tried to use her her robe to swing from
the roof into her apartment and missed
and fell to her death almost one year to
the day later that Eddie Murphy picked
her up
oh she actually doing really awesome
really did she mean money and like
better herself he even spoke about it
years later and said it was unfortunate
but it kind of worked out the way he
handled it cuz he wasn't like gonna
front or anything he was just like you
know he went on The Tonight Show the
same week I was like ya know just
picture that with me about what you do
repeat that translate that car man she
look lonely you know me ma'am
I like to help people while they speak
to my very [ __ ] life the main rooms
two miles away we be help to mother
my mom works two miles the gross [ __ ]
[ __ ]
if you ought to being a comedian my mom
has to walk tomorrow for gross fool
we're taking it and that'll show media
now my brother said that right so what'd
you do stay at home and waited for this
is a fat ass bro who had a fundraiser to
sell cupcakes so you could get our money
for our for college bro first to be a
nurse that's not enough stupid be racist
I think they find for being raised iike
this for the idiot man like he'll be
like yo catch people sleeping they
something stupid about him but he
finally caught a black woman sleeping
and then he wrote something about it and
it was totally racist it's not funny
I pushed her somebody told him about it
my brother little [ __ ] anybody made us
think exactly yeah you always say is
tree trunks release the fool all legs
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
overpricing going out a seven-ten like
actual work some hard-ass rooms man no
nothing room where you like you at this
room the people with different sets need
a whole new Act there was no where
Montebello California it's funny you say
that because it's a bit of people that
went to that room and just said now I'm
not comedian you know with a killer can
we didn't go up on stage destroys a room
and they're afraid to go up do your job
to be a comedian you know you're gonna
go up the part of it but I'm gonna bomb
that's fine you know you have bad days
today's gonna be worse people look
beyond my you were up there bombing like
a soldier bomb with dignity now they're
doing somebody else's [ __ ] like
what's-his-face Corey Holcomb even has a
solid comic you know master stranger one
just several three or has the hair guru
billion dollars i spicy salt black
pepper and it's cool because the vendor
has a little bit it's funny man because
it felt like if I'm kill monger with the
same after a food station
so that means and he was and when they
left him behind in a movie he was in
Oakland and in the same so that we were
cute I got killed by little cop right
they progressing from being kill monger
was the other very movie right now
oh don't tell me yeah came home and his
you know what we're moving taco shop
[Laughter]
is that I had to audition for that role
it had no lines Perez bro you promoted
that movie there's Casablanca
Johnny Sanchez brother promoting talk
with Shop Boys The Godfather pretty good
good Rose your role turned out to be
chopped up so much it's unrecognizable
that's confusing and I it's not not you
in the best light but the entire movie
silly every fun I loved I Sonya you did
yeah I really want to do that story yes
yeah I've been obsessed with that she
didn't smash anybody's ankle somebody
she paid somebody right yeah all right
big dog she still denies all that though
good she got busted though right she
denies that she knew about knew about
what they did trying to get it for
conspiracy yeah but they still banned
her for life yeah yeah can't be doing
that she the mall was good bro the
moment looking like Howard Cosell huh
yeah no I'm the Marvin Tanya she look
like that she look like she could be the
head coach of the Green Bay Packers she
don't let the old owner of the name
Jerry Jones Tomlin named Allison Janney
yes she's the better than she was third
movie yes she was
she played the program like the head one
of the exact Siddhant in private parts
she's a West Wing for a long time
she won Emmys on that show she was an
American Beauty yeah American Beauty is
the drugged-up housewife one line what
yeah yeah yeah she's on like whatever
Halla doll or whatever you wanna call
this old way they call mother's little
helpers I wanna start going through maze
medicine cabinet oh yeah yeah I don't
have a good [ __ ] though if you want
benadryl I got you though right I don't
believe her because she's got em all in
and her dad's a doctor so I assume
there's some real good [ __ ] in there
full sail west wing is the best
that's what Monica Lewinsky said to use
the whole can of Aqua Net
oh no hell no I use Aqua Net like every
day for less in Fontana catch me now
three Aqua Net like the whole can the
label is like a little net yeah yeah no
but yeah a little get all high and
trying to cast a monopod and bamboo
[Laughter]
my favorite movie a lot of time right
now oh brother were out there oh that's
a great one evening yet the Sun went
down I watched that one with your
boyfriend John Krasinski where it's all
quiet the whole time
oh you had that's amazing man I can't
watch the movie but the office do
another movie oh yeah you want him to
look at the camera yeah
when is Pamphylia Isaac say about like
jim says Pam what's up Matt so yeah uh
we got dubious to the podcast and of
comedy or sketch Wesley in the couch I'm
a lawyer I'm applying to med school this
year yeah yeah there's nothing there's
nothing scandalous about med school so
what a word huh get the med school oh
yeah yeah that's why it's taking me this
long coach I'll do that oh yeah I was
pretty med for two years but then I
started working in a psych department
helping them out and I like that stuff
better so I switched I was break him
[Laughter]
so you're a lawyer yeah immigration let
the real peace that I love so any coffee
everywhere no she will get coffee for
everybody
[Music]
she passed to be a lawyer but the show
got canceled oh no we're too bad the
show got canceled on Fox this year
Brooklyn nine-nine nine just to bring
back football but they but they picked
up little rails show Fox it though
yeah well little rail like Michael yes
Jesse just hilarious she's gonna be in
it does the urban every morning she does
like beam of God that was like yeah like
rants on something yeah see I hear about
Chris Brown right they stood her a whole
rat followers she's like when we met her
at the and a show at Mike Epps and I'm
like who is this chick and then like she
had a start stand-up friend if she was
trying to do stand-up and she had like a
makeup room already ready a hairdresser
[Laughter]
and then her mom walks you know smoking
weed party van Eyck she walks out and
her mom walks in and it's more like we
they crossed each other like you know
like she noticed and then went her she
comes back in the mom man I was telling
her mom was telling me you so funny you
uh-oh
but now she said I saw a clip of her
acting on the show
good actress bro you know sometimes you
can see a comedian know a comedian to
her act you could tell like
where they just come out of real fast
yeah how could they write good what they
write good for her
and simbad play the [ __ ] father oh
he's back baby
dude that's been around didn't ever
laughter he has to be I arrest somehow
bro yeah I don't know but he almost fell
he's finished painting now yeah Simbel I
already know because uh you know what I
read and what club owners told me that
that know the IRS went to the comedy
club to collect that check but they were
heckling him embarrassed super super
super nice and he makes everybody feel
comfortable that the IRA escaped it came
with friend and he just make small
payments every month and then he goes to
his shows and I think that I really want
you to pay that's it right no even if
you're five million but you want to pay
me he was uh one of those people that
cop said our sovereign state sovereign
citizen claim that if I were to reclaim
that you know what that is
[Laughter]
from what I understand from uh the only
part of the sheriff they don't follow
the LAPD only County stole a show
Sheriff feds but nope local police they
don't believe in that and like and then
we asked the cop goes though you can't
arrest them
you know we arrested [ __ ] you know
ten wants to do but you know they'd
always make up a big stink yeah they go
after my accounts which are you know
like just talk me in every way because
either are connected some of them are
judges he said okay well they thought I
just like to officially know a bunch of
by size get it pull over by a by the
Border Patrol we got going it come on
you register the channel anyway we lost
over in sovereign citizen
[Laughter]
this was did I pay the IRS $20 a month
I mean you died all your kids got all
the money and interest right no only
child support does no Charles the portal
I ask them interests in California they
keep adding interest in penalties even
after the child turns 18 no until you
pay who's gonna manage that account yep
and and the mom or whoever the
non-custodial no the custodial parent
whoever that was gets all the penalty
and interest when I one last comment
Stan
I'm also old like 75,000 or 65,000 four
inches another it went up to a hundred
forty thousand one hundred ten thousand
tell us how much you owed after kill
Lucas is when she filed when she filed
my daughter saw me on TV yeah and she
thought there were dollars involved
I wasn't even making nine thousand here
but I yeah but see although we didn't
have the wherewithal though to go back
to court and get reassessed based on
what you really need and well I know
they just
based on whatever they thought I don't
even know what they based it on because
I wasn't there this is so long ago based
on based on the quality of his yeah that
was that's crazy man what's up with the
immigration law right now a lot of
people going out for the money grab yeah
Trump has made everything really really
difficult so a lot more cases are going
through so a lot of people are able to
kind of get into that business right now
if they weren't previously and there's a
lot of people have been ripped off
though over years right you know what
immigration services because they can
there's a paper that you pay 500 bucks
you can fill out yourself but they'll
charge you to do it okay but yeah I mean
I think a lot of people give them hope
and they just tell them yeah we can fix
for you and even though they even though
that you clearly can't you know how many
DUI is you guys right because it's even
hard to get in when you have a clean
record did you say you gave trouble
don't ever clean citizenship Robles yeah
you can you can no I was saying claiming
citizenship you can you can't legally
you can't say that you're a citizen like
on a formal application or something on
a job application they can't ask if
you're a citizen though they can only
ask if you're documented to work and in
the country of a work permit yeah
permitted or you have a green card or
whatever
but they can't
they can't ask you any more that's all
you're right on the application yeah
everything matter of you know like well
border trip can ask when I go to AK
somewhere like or working a job the
paper always did right for the work here
[Laughter]
I saw this thing on TV that's big no in
Tijuana bro it's called but then they
put like the regular corn on top and in
the mayonnaise copied in LA figured out
the it was what 19 pixels or like it
filled with corn all right people you
bro have you'll be like like you're
already that [ __ ] fat
we'll be like yeah no he will not make
it though full everything in my dad say
he could make it home handled every
[ __ ] minute are we [ __ ] pizza he
could make it home
Chinese fool he [ __ ] it all up make it
at home and won't eat like the damage
bro like considering a pizza chinese was
wrong with [ __ ] boys like you know
hop skip and a jump the last time I went
to Mexico I went to son lease and I went
to some club and the guy kept charging
me overcharging me for my drinks because
I didn't know the conversion and then my
friend was like hey you're getting
[ __ ] screwed over you're paying like
$40 a drink and I was like you know
people go check out drama club people
find out all that she's been my butt
commander man yeah he's all dude he's
all up on YouTube and I know he's big
he's huge for that size documentary
called nautical music and they were
talking to man they talked to a
documentary some guy from from the
valley he's doing that type of music
right but if not from Mexico so this
fool hired somebody to write his songs
so this food goes least this kinda
struck this kid like a he like a coke
dealer two against and and that guy role
of song for him like the guy like the
guy getting him information about his
life
a there adolfo record inna Sinaloa they
know this you never will he Nia EB well
you're hired
tamale pass Tamela that food got all
those notes down about his life and
Rolla called
Ledo for him as a challenge I say a
record you know for sure yeah he was a
ghostwriter oh yeah you tell me story
boom from so that puts that okay he
wrote the song would you like it they go
see then I got give much a cache of a
whop full of money brought her with
pocket ago Toma enough and then I feel
walking away talk it's kind of money
left for kid ofr [ __ ] panoramas day
not even a team homes you got people of
money yeah you got people to [ __ ] this
song
you gotta talk [ __ ] on TV get kill you
[ __ ] so this footer
he has no like I'm like he wants to be a
little commander so bad so he goes all
the way to his hometown bro truth to get
the feeling of it so he could write
better and he's a he's over there with
his uncle bro and making somewhere
Sinaloa let you know you know in a big
ranch and his [ __ ] uncle opens up a
bag and stabbed it and it's full of meth
bro but then I show other food they were
talking [ __ ] about real culture people
and songs to be slick and you know their
bell all into it killed
they don't forgive you for anything and
what happened to pin up today I saw a
video of him dead bro
yeah I was talking [ __ ] Instagram yeah
it's not like over here they'll let you
keep a passenger keyboard warrior over
there the white be off the earth yeah
when I see the commander and fresney you
at the fattiest the first five minutes
of the show with two fools with a K just
shooting at the skies I don't know if
the ship was for real there were blanks
right there that period be that
there is where I found a video of me
dancing I like to go to video that you
can see the photo it's in its blog so
you can just poke at it we see the video
yeah and I said okay but the letters
were fun you brought it about that video
you know I don't whatever you do nothing
no es division ghazals and it shows
these four trucks like they're all
getting happy they're out there like
taking guns out bro camera for the
future no the camera is falling bro it
was a Fiesta jingles have no cops
hmm like and then you have to sing happy
birthday at that day so how do you do
that you go for blasting and it is our
first communion
[Laughter]
uh yeah I'm from Fontana but my parents
are from El Salvador
that's funny people do people ever tell
you you don't sound like it for people
Union microburst Amador a man named
talked about they were like coming out
of the jungle man like my dad will start
with dory El Salvador to the house you
probably know Salvador ten years before
that or 15 years or how old that girl is
they cut their grass with machetes in
the Sun whoa Wow what's up with that
flower that grows like out of like like
a cactus or something it's like a white
flower that they put in teeth yeah
ya know she like this for black is my
house but there's no blacks in our
street that fools just racist because
every time you see a black person who
wonder we're doing bad stuff so [ __ ] him
so he came in was his daughter or
translator because you want you guys to
turn off the music it's kind of loud and
all this stuff right I'm looking at him
bro like all coked out I'm trying to I'm
trying to bite my ear off at the same
time
and then you know it was I tell him I
don't know how you could say that but
I'm a loser the translation if I steer
in Spanish but could you please tell him
that I said to go [ __ ] himself hard I
think all me would have done any kind of
talking about order again and then she
said they said no mom is way he's gonna
control every movement in that building
huh yeah and you're a sovereign citizen
well when I was in with my son and he
was out of town and I was staying there
and cleaning up and all that stuff I was
trying to clean this apart but it was a
mess it was so messy
but he was out of town for like one
night I was vacuuming at 6 p.m. not too
late 6 p.m. he lived right downstairs he
comes up and he was like I realized I
wasn't you and I didn't speak Spanish
with him even though I probably could
have but I looked at him and he went
like come on and I always like what like
it's 6 o'clock and I'm vacuuming like
that's a problem at 6 o'clock and then
try to get you kicked out because he
thought I lived there with my son but I
was just like hanging out there one day
cleaning for you and everything I left
everything there bro oh I don't care
about no deposit there was like this go
of sugar and [ __ ] my refrigerator broke
some guy gave me food he's the guy get
some guy from Ventura gave me a bunch of
dishes and boxes full of roaches I've
never ever if anybody listen to me right
now don't ever ever ever receive
anything from anybody houses in a
cardboard box from their house it's
always called eggs well if you gonna
back me up exterminator that's how you
[ __ ] move
around yes bedbugs as well each Roach
eggs has anywhere from 30 to 50 roaches
inside that roach and all of those
roaches are gonna have 30 to 50 as we
have Rocha from Ventura bro
gangbanging with I'm sure there was some
Chinese roaches in their white lies
matter
speaking to the brown road to focus
gentrify under-cabinet do speak to the
brown road chip you need to go to the
bathroom the little white ones are cool
though man white lies matters but
hardcore out there makes him a man
Mexico Mexico is for real done but in a
new they make it sound like food a dying
everyday words but you're swimming in
Mexico everybody's somebody's women next
to you but the best medicine into Mexico
huh you just can't you can get a lot of
[ __ ] without a prescription yeah yeah
that's crazy you could get it there's a
better way
what the malla was so choppy no people
from Mexico yeah I had a
I'm a material for my special charm
translate this come from
people have met and I had to date this
girl who was what a Marlin you want me
to call my grandma finder will find that
[ __ ] saw me one time right and then
later on she didn't see me and then she
told me that her mom said more and I was
like shocked
[ __ ] where should the CBP shouldn't
see my boss but no man was shocked she
was light-skinned all the way live I
believe it was only not [ __ ] Mexican
people but I was amazed because that
does cause she was Tommy shooting an
East ending and I would like to target
avenged my mom' always talk [ __ ] like
he's too black about you I won't expect
his breath smells too fast end of the
worst that broke lights ya know the
first time I saw it between our own
people bro and I couldn't believe it but
that's not thing about it yeah we're
Mexican we see darker people can bunch
of Camellia bro then you have idiot to
talk [ __ ] about that just like this
millennial social justice warriors
that's a racist joke I just pointed out
like they forget that the anger doesn't
exist in our culture to be racist like
they want everything you have to lecture
and tell everybody to be better than
that and yeah I'm not a dictator
you saw my summer potentials I think
what I still excel in life no and it
doesn't make any sense to pretend like
it doesn't exist
you know they want to hide it from
society yeah
like Cheech and Chong right right I
never considered teach Marines character
as a bad Mexican or is he look he making
us look bad because I never considered
his character for Mexican more like a
Chicano guy who lived in the hood yeah
you know dude
the one horse out they were more Mexican
with a pool they were passed out outside
in the band yeah they were broken up but
I could see how some people of that
generation you know who are in college
who are educated you know people like
probably like that guy from there
senator probably recruits
Ted Cruz people at that party nah man
he's not representing us I need to stay
back from Cheech people protested when
Paul Rodriguez uh they don't show aka
Pablo they say that that that doesn't
represent us and when I'm when exactly
he never said that
over Freddy princess don't show he would
Porto Rican playing a Mexican and
Chicano man and all of LULAC national
counselor Raza Ghana
oh no roar you know like I said this is
like I'm Mexican I know like every time
we have a left you know on TV he's not
representing us why should we represent
it should just be a [ __ ] show that's
funny right I don't look at any white
actor on TV or actress and say that
person is me that person represents
really like the one I talked about the
one I talked about that I did notice as
a teenager growing up was that two
people Dolly Parton and Roseanne and
that's because they grew up in poverty
and that was my life and that that is
what I saw I was I never saw poor white
people on TV working-class poor white
people I ever saw was made with children
right they report to
could that fool never have meal yeah
they didn't have any oh the first time I
saw a woman be like Peggy though I love
woman be like pig with all the other
shows a man like like Garbo it was a
cartoon on oh yeah that mom was always
coming out of the groceries Oh like that
was a field typical stereotype right
there like those moms was always like
even though you really know eight is
enough
any other moms moms the moms those moms
all disappeared into the background
Peggy was playing a stereotypical all
the stereotypical roles that men would
joke about you know spends all my money
doesn't cook weather doesn't whatever
and then but she played all those
stereotypes and excelled as like this
crazy like badass woman like she ain't
gonna do anything she doesn't want to do
or that doesn't benefit her in some way
yeah her sisters had the show double
treble in the 80s they were like one was
there were fashion designers on the show
they're twins
she had amazing hair yeah yeah rod Bundy
I know I want to get by Bundy on the
show at David Faustino on the show he
has a podcast I really want him to be a
guest
I felt bad one time I would be the first
guy there when you when you're the first
one or somebody live and then you way
around you still the only one I felt
like you guys are both taking a [ __ ]
look at each other
are you closing the door slowly yeah
then I wrote down the only person here
Al Bundy was eating toast the crumbs are
the toaster toaster leavings crumbs
don't a toaster remember does yeah a
John Hughes movie by the way Charlie
huland broke accent way too much when he
got emotional attorney well they're
talking about sons anarchie that's right
characters I'm telling ya you said you
saw him in that shell undeclared where
he was a tiny little guy he is tiny but
they make him look big and like tough in
them in that show they make him look
like Brad Pitt and you know John Silver
being a horndog yes somebody put some
drama up there too katey sagal let gene
simmons smash she was a backup singer
though and says yeah yeah so she toured
with a lot of people and Philippa yeah
man Elysa a big killer from Phoenix
Arizona is too much from [ __ ] snap keep
it up to Phoenix she was a backup singer
best business on the rows are probably
the room
did I ever tell you you were my yeah
that too oh yeah that was the Johnny
Carson because that song also became
like no no there was another song that
it became like the anthem for the Iraq
war right it was her other one after
that because there's a couple for
there's like three super famous song
[Music]
[Laughter]
find you it you can find us at drama
club pod Twitter and Instagram you can
find us on reddit at drama the
underscore underscore pond yeah man yeah
we read a good ass book about our
Hollywood drama from the eighties yes
dumb book that dance team symbol
well Jerry Bruckheimer Jerry Bruckheimer
there were teams and they did the
ability was calm what's the title to the
gentleman it's called high concept high
concept but it's got a print out a plan
how to find that book it's like it's
like if you read all the books about
Hollywood this book tie them all
together and even tied in the og trial
because I'm done Simpson's drug dealer
was Kato Kaelin drug dealer and the
night of the murder his drug dealer
testified he disappeared his drug didn't
testify that he went to go give Kato
Kaelin some some methamphetamine at a
Burger King parking lot and OJ Simpson
was in the back and it was stricken from
the record those taken from the record
over the night of the murder stricken
from the jury what do you mean
but I could have paid them off though
like hey I was with you anything no the
night of the murder right right before
before before next week because they
were trying to establish that he was
high when he did and was on meth because
no party no party do you think we can
get kato kaelin on our podcast could it
be the boner I think no bone to pick
with you
what's up for a three off social media
prefer water at Rodrigo towards Union
Junior spelled junior so what I want to
know about oh yeah
[Music]
no actually Joe Rogan's didn't sell
directly to Ricky Martin his publicist
or somebody went to looking for drugs at
one time and murder what time Giorgio
telling a story with Bobby Brown well
her dad had admitted to doing a lot of
stuff helping her out
being a what do you call it a
codependent sort of mm-hmm person what
do you call it an enabling me when it's
running the canal I want to say it's
from the same people who did Amy oh no
no that was a good one it just they want
to release it like the same way I really
felt bad for her daughter when you run
when they had that show the bomb a
little startup or slow and they were
gonna go shopping and I'm the older kids
you know they were like being older kid
than those little girls behind the one
that passed away and like you could tell
that she didn't she don't know like how
to be a little girl or how to just be
anybody because I'm just she just said
she's just bought like seven much a hat
yeah she just had nothing to do
something for her
and then I think a little I think I
showed mother's day and they couldn't
they couldn't find Whitney she came out
of that bath pull of small gray the
piano hearts why she was mad because she
didn't think as for Mother's Day she
should be spending time with her kids
and even if anyone yeah she had a party
for women she went to the bathroom and
then she come back and she was home like
hey and then her daughter ended up
marrying her adopted brother right yeah
that was really the same way that her
mom in a bathtub you think she died of
heartbreak that little girl I think I
think that drugs tried it became easier
to get to do who raised his own wife
right what did Paul Mooney say bomb some
[ __ ] out there grown their own
dress [ __ ] raisin [ __ ] funny we
come back to a Homburg morning show up
here bro where's that take you ask you
for Paso Robles bro
that's romantic yeah I'm gonna be in San
Francisco at the Warfield November 2nd
so go check that out everybody else
tonight I'm gonna be at eat nasty of
Colorado at Sky you'd casino but we call
it nacho Casino once again tell
everybody where they can find the
podcast and get all the scoop we're on
iTunes stitcher anywhere you can listen
to podcasts at drama club pod before you
guys go anywhere we got to tell you guys
man about what we heard about people
moving broke people
getting like a bunch of bots just to
like their pockets or can move up Oh to
subscribe moving up with it's funny that
you say that because people do that [ __ ]
for their videos - all that stuff
telling us to do it like Audio boom we
went with them for ads and it was a lot
of money but you know also a lot of
money they all tons of money - other
podcast listeners yeah and yeah we're
getting mail before they owe us anymore
yeah the five figures and it's yeah they
ran on a theme well Lisa said it but
they ran the podcast please like a
[ __ ] Ponzi scheme Broadway well I'm
not saying that I'm saying it feels like
[Music]
no there's it just feels like something
bad so I'm getting out before they owe
us any more and before we do any more
work any heavy lifting them interested
yeah there's but some people are talking
class-action lawsuit and you know they
were but now they had to abandon it
because they didn't raise the money to
buy this company was so foolish ago
drama club was dance at me on iTunes
Spotify SoundCloud wherever you can find
a podcast and also check out Felipe
Esparza Rodrigo Torres was so full
podcast Lisa and I we did I enchilada
casserole podcast yeah my coming up yeah
episode 39 drop in drop in drama club
pod yeah find us what's up fool thank
you very much for being a guest hell
yeah thank you